[موسيقى] لقد
فقدت نوعًا ما كل ما كنت أعرفه
عن حياتي
عندما أصبحت مبتورًا ، لم أكن أعتقد
أن الرياضة التنافسية ستكون
متاحة لي مرة أخرى
، قيل إن الجندي غالبًا ما يتم
تعريفه بما يمكنه تحمله
بدلاً من ما هو عليه  يمكن إلحاق الضرر
بآلاف الجنود في جميع أنحاء
العالم ،
فإن تكلفة الحرب هي شيء
يصبح جزءًا من حياتهم اليومية
بعد فترة طويلة من توقف الصراعات.
لقد حدث كل هذا
حقًا عندما سُئلت
أثناء لعب الجولف يومًا ما إذا كنت
سأتحدث في
ملعب هيدلي وهو
مركز إعادة التأهيل العسكري البريطاني وحقيقة
عندما ذهبت إلى هناك ورأيت
ما رأيته وعدد الأشخاص
هناك وذاك  كانت في عام
2009. أعرف ما فعلته لعبة الجولف من أجلي
وأنا معاق وأدركت أن
لعبة الجولف هي اللعبة الوحيدة التي أعرف
أنها يمكن أن تلعبها في
ملعب مستو مع أشخاص
يتمتعون بصحة جيدة.  كان لدى mpson مهنة ناجحة بشكل كبير
في صناعة الجولف حيث
أدار أمثال نيك فالدو جريج نورمان وفيجاي
سينغ ، ويستخدم الآن جهات اتصاله وخبرته
للمساعدة في توفير
الفرص للمحاربين القدامى في اللعبة التي
تم نشرها في أفغانستان في عام 2012
وحوالي خمسة ونصف  بعد أشهر
من الجولة
أثناء قيادتي لدورية ، وقفت على
عبوة ناسفة مرتجلة
كنت على دراية
بمؤسسة encores بينما كنت في ملعب هيدلي ،
حضرت حدثًا تذوقيًا ليوم واحد وحصلت على
نوع من ضرب بعض كرات الجولف
وكان هذا هو الوقت الذي كنت فيه  كنت لا تزال
على كرسي متحرك ، لذا فإن
ضرب كرات الجولف من على كرسي متحرك
لم يكن شيئًا اعتقدت يومًا أنني سأكون
قادرًا على القيام به ، ولكن بطريقة ما تمكنت من
ضرب عدد قليل منها جيدًا ومن
هناك عض حشرة الجولف ،
فمن السهل جدًا الدخول  صدفة
عندما تتعرض للإصابة وتعتقد أن
الحياة كما تعلم قد انتهت ، لكن
العودة إلى ملعب الجولف
والتعرف على أشخاص جدد ، إنها رياضة
اجتماعية وأعتقد أنها تلعب دورًا أكبر في
هذا النوع من
بالإضافة إلى توفير فرص اللعب
والاجتماعية وإقامة شراكات مع
نوادي الجولف ، تساعد المؤسسة أيضًا في توفير
فرص عمل وفرص عمل
للمحاربين القدامى مثل
فيكرانت غورانج المعروف باسم g ،
لذلك رأيت يومًا ما جون سيمبسون كان يعمل
في رمز هيدلي
كنت أقول شيئًا عن لعبة الجولف ،
فأنا أقول لك إعادة التأهيل من خلال لعبة الجولف ، وفي
البداية اعتقدت أنك تعرف أن ما
يتحدث عنه هو أنه لا يمكنك لعب الجولف الذي
تعرفه بساق واحدة ،
لذا في البداية أعطوني
مكان العمل في لعبة كولواي
جولف داون في لندن ، لذا  لقد عملت مع um
callaway لمدة تسعة أشهر أه قمت
بالتسويق والآن أفعل شيئًا
آخر مثل
القيام بالتصوير وتحرير الفيديو
على أساس الدورة التدريبية وهو أمر رائع حقًا
مع أحداث مثل كأس سيمبسون
ودورة على غرار كأس ريدر يتم لعبها
بين  قدامى المحاربين من الولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة ، وقد ساعدت المؤسسة أيضًا في
رعاية بعض المواهب الاستثنائية التي مارست
لعبة الجولف ، وحصلت على أول إعاقة لي
في عام 2014
من 28 حيث  أنت تعرف أن الجميع يفعلون ذلك
وقد عملت فيه للتو واستخدمته
كوظيفة مثل الغرض من الاستيقاظ في
الصباح
، لقد عمل كما لو كنت لا تستطيع أن تتخيل
اللعبة في لعبته
على مر السنين وانخفض إلى
أرقام فردية بسرعة كبيرة
والآن فترته للمحترفين وهو يلعب في
بعض الجولات الأقل
في أوروبا ، فقد حصل على عدد من
الأرقام القياسية التي
فاز بها بالفعل في البطولة ، أعني أنه أمر
غير عادي تمامًا عندما يكون قد تعرض لبتر أعلى من
الركبة
وكنا نقيس قيادته
فقط الآن في  أرض التدريب ،
كانت مسافة 300 ياردة ، وهو
أمر مذهل بساق واحدة ، وأعتقد
أن المؤسسة قد انتقلت من قوة إلى
قوة على مر السنين مع
رعاة بارزين بما في ذلك أرنولد بالمر العظيم ،
وهو محارب قديم في الجيش نفسه ومع
عدد
الجنود المصابين في  الملايين في
الولايات المتحدة
وحدها ، ستستمر لعبة الجولف في المساعدة في
إعادة بناء الحياة
لسنوات عديدة قادمة ، ولن أغير حياتي
وأنا أعلم أنني قابلت بعض الأشخاص الرائعين الذين
تغلبوا على بعض الأماكن الرائعة مثل  حسنًا من خلال
لعبة غولف الجولف وأعطاني الأساس الموجود في
الملعب الحياة مرة أخرى
لك